In Pakistan, a suicide bombing targeting Christians kills at least 65...
...and a Pakistani Taliban faction has claimed responsibility.
An elected official and 30 militants were killed...
...during the attack between security forces and PKK militants in southeast Turkey.
In Jordan, United Nations Secretary General Ban Ki-Moon...
...says the recapture of the historic city of Palmyra from ISIS by the Syria government...
...is a success to preserve as a human asset.
As a symbol of friendship,...
...South Korea prepares to send back the remains of 36 Chinese soldiers...
...who fought during the Korean War.
And finally from Moldova,...
...thousands of people rally on the street in the capital Chisinau,...
...calling for unification with EU member Romania.